The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Next
hand out-- thermodynamics.
Yes.
I love thermodynamics.
All right.
So what is thermodynamics?
So thermodynamics and
kinetics I feel go together,
but for kind of weird reasons
we do thermodynamics now
and we do kinetics at the very
last unit of the semester.
Part of the reason for this is
that kinetics is often a unit
that students can
pick up really fast,
and so I like doing it at
the end when everything--
your world is sort
of crazy and you
have something that you can
get a grasp on pretty easily
for the last unit.
So anyway, I'll tell you a
little bit about kinetics
now because we won't get
to a lot of it until later.
So thermodynamics deals with
energy change and spontaneity
of reactions.
And thermodynamics brings you
three of my favorite things
in chemistry, which are
[MUSIC PLAYING] delta H,
[CYMBAL CRASH] Delta S,
and [DRUM ROLL] delta G.
I love these.
I live my life
around these things.
I believe entropy should
always be increasing.
And I love nothing
more than free energy.
That's great stuff.
So today we're going to talk
about delta H. Next week we
have delta S and delta G.
What about kinetics?
What does kinetics bring us?
Well, kinetics brings us the
rate or speed of a reaction.
It can bring us fast
reactions and it
can bring us slow reactions.
I like kinetics too.
I kind of like the fast
to be honest with you.
All right.
So thermodynamics and kinetics.
One. thermodynamics tells
us whether something
is going to happen
spontaneously or not,
but kinetics tells us the
rate at which it happens.
So let's just think of
an example for a minute.
You may have heard--
this commercial happens
a lot around Valentine's Day.
Diamonds are forever.
So actually,
thermodynamically, graphite
is favorable to diamonds.
It's more stable.
So graphite or coal--
thermodynamically,
this is the stuff.
Diamonds-- diamond
is not forever.
That's really a
kinetic statement.
It's there for a very long time,
but you know it isn't inert.
So here's an important question.
What is the best ring for one
geek to give another geek?
The thermodynamically
stable one or one
that is more kinetically slow to
react, more stable, more inert.
Inert is reaction.
What do you-- I should have
a clicker question on this,
I know.
I don't know what you think.
But actually, the answer is, in
my opinion, neither of these.
Come on.
There's only really one ring
that any geek really wants.
Green Lantern's
ring has the power
of chemistry at your fingertips.
Who cares if something's inert?
If you're the Green Lantern
you can do whatever.
So that's the ring.
Anyway--
AUDIENCE: What
about the one ring?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Oh, one ring.
Yeah.
I like the Green Lantern
ring, but I guess next-- maybe
we should open a blog on this.
It's a really
important question.
So let's think about
bonding for a minute.
So thermodynamics is telling
us about energy change.
It's telling us
about spontaneity.
And so we need to think
about energy that's going in.
So kinetics is telling
us about how fast.
Thermodynamics is really
telling us about stability.
How stable is something?
How much does it cost
to break it apart?
So we're back to bond
association energies.
We have the change
in the dissociation
energy E to the little d.
It's the energy to break a bond.
We've seen this plot before.
Now we have methane.
We're breaking off a
hydrogen from it, which
is actually very hard to do.
Scientists would love to
break apart methane and make
methanol, but it's
a hard thing to do.
Up here we have
unfavorable reactions.
When the atoms are
too close, then you
have a sweet spot where
the positions of the atoms
are just right to form a bond.
That's when you get methane.
And then, if you put in
energy, you can pull this off,
is they go far apart
with the radius this way.
Your bond will dissociate.
You always have to put energy
in to get it to dissociate.
So now we can think about
it-- we thought about this
in terms of bond dissociation.
We've seen this
before, but now we
can think about it in
terms of a new term, which
is delta H B, or bond enthalpy.
So bond enthalpy is the
change in heat accompanying
the dissociation of a
bond and that's measured
at a constant pressure.
In fact, if we relate
delta H to Delta E-- delta
H equals delta E plus whatever
change in pressure or volume.
And often, this term
is pretty small,
so people often really
think about reactions
in terms of these being
pretty similar to each other.
So for gases, the difference
really is 1% to 2%.
And if you're talking
about a liquid or a solid
it's really a
negligible difference.
So we often really kind of
think about these things
in the same way.
We think about the energy
going into a system
to break the bond, or we think
about the bond enthalpies.
And bond enthalpy, delta H,
is often easier to measure,
so it's very convenient.
So again, bond
enthalpies You always
have to put energy in if
you're going to break a bond.
So it's always going
to be positive.
It always takes heat.
It always takes something
to break a bond.
And so breaking a
bond is endothermic.
Heat must be added.
Whereas bond formation
is exothermic.
Heat is being released.
And so we can think
about this-- again,
when you form a bond those--
we saw with MO theory--
there's more electrons in lower
energy in the bonding orbitals
than in the
antibonding orbitals.
They're happy.
This is a lower energy state.
So if you're going
to break that bond,
breaking up is hard to do.
And there's a song that
verifies that statement.
Breaking up is hard to do.
You always have to have heat.
But when you go from
that stable stay
out-- when you form
those bonds, it's
like kind of the married couple,
often get a little boring.
They're in a low energy state.
It's hard to get
them out of the house
and so they release
all of their energy
and they form this nice,
little, happy, stable couple.
So when you do bond formation
that's an exothermic process.
So we can talk about
standard bond enthalpies.
When you see this
little circle up there
that means it's a value that's
at standard conditions, where
your reactants and products
are in their standard states.
And so we can think about what
are some delta H or some bond
enthalpies for different kinds
of carbon hydrogen bonds.
So here's our friend methane.
If you're going to
pull off a hydrogen
you have to put
energy in to do that,
and the bond enthalpy
for that is 438.
Now we can think about some
other kinds of carbon bonds.
We talked about this one.
We have it here
in the classroom.
So if we pull off a hydrogen
from that, it's plus 410.
So similar but not the same.
If you now substitute
three flourines for three
of the hydrogens that
changes your value
a little bit, but not much.
If you substitute chlorine
it changes it a lot more.
Same with bromine.
So it depends.
The bond enthalpy depends on
what else is around that atom
that you're pulling around.
So it's not always
the same value.
It's different.
It depends on what
else is there.
So often you'll have a table
that will report mean bond
enthalpies.
And they take all
the bonds enthalpies
and they get the mean
value, and they're usually
within 8% of each other.
And for a carbon
hydrogen bond it's
around 412 is the
mean bond enthalpy.
But when you're using
mean bond enthalpies
to calculate something,
you have to realize
that there can be some pretty
big differences depending
on what's around that bond
that you're going to break.
So those are some
bond enthalpies.
Why are they important?
Well, they're important
because the difference
in bond enthalpies between
a product and a reactant
can tell you about the
enthalpy of that reaction.
The enthalpy of the reaction
of breaking of bonds
and forming new bonds, or the
enthalpy of reaction, which
is delta H R-- sub R. And
that is in the standard state
in that case.
So let's talk about
enthalpies of reactions.
So we have this symbol again.
Standard bond enthalpy
for a reaction.
So if it's a little B
it's a bond enthalpy.
If it's a little R it's
a reaction enthalpy.
If it's negative value it means
it's an exothermic reaction,
and if it's a positive
value it means that it's
an endothermic reaction.
So we'll use these
terms a lot and you'll
get very familiar with them.
So let's look at some
examples of reactions.
And here is one of my
favorites, and it is yes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It has it's own song.
- (SINGING) Photosynthesis Aah.
Photosynthesis.
Aah.
Photosynthesis does not involve
a camera or a synthesizer,
although that's interesting too.
Photosynthesis is how the plants
take in light from the sun
and turn it into energy.
It's actually a thing on
which most life depends here
on the planet Earth.
Photosynthesis.
Aah.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: OK.
That gives you an idea.
Unfortunately, every time
you will hear the word
photosynthesis you'll go Ah.
It happens.
I'm sorry about that.
So photosynthesis.
Amazing reaction.
People right now are trying
to duplicate it in industry
to solve the energy problem.
Good luck with that.
But I know.
I wish them good luck.
That would be awesome.
We use the opposite of that
reaction for our energy.
So we take sugar and use
oxygen to break it down,
which is an awesome
thing because this
has a really negative
enthalpy of reaction
minus 2816 kilojoules per mole.
It's huge.
And we store this in
something called ATP.
So since this is-- and I'm going
to need the help of the TAs
for a minute because we're
going to do a very quick demo
at the end of today's class.
This reaction is
exothermic big time.
It's a big negative,
which raises the question,
if it's that exothermic--
really big value.
We have sugar in air.
Why we should feel heat?
Heat should be released.
So I think we should do
this demo now and see
whether that's true.
So I have a bag of sugar and
it is sealed under nitrogen
so there's no oxygen in there.
And I forgot my safety glasses
but I'll try to-- sorry
about the front room.
I should have had a stellar
announcement that you
might want to sit back.
But I'm going to cut
this open and let O2 in.
So there should be a
lot of heat coming out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the things
inside it individually wrapped?
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Oh, you know what?
They are individually wrapped.
All right, so this
is not going to work.
So I need the TAs to
come down here, please,
and you've got to
help me unwrap them.
Has anyone done
the experiment yet?
Do you feel heat coming out?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: You do?
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
I better try it up here.
Let's see.
I'm going or unwrap mine.
It's not working very well.
So it turns out
that heat should be
released but this is very slow.
So we don't feel the heat when
we unwrap our Hershey's Kisses.
I encourage everyone to try
this experiment at least once.
But the way that we harness
this energy in our bodies
is that we have catalysts,
which are enzymes,
that speed up the reaction.
And that's how we get the full
force of this reaction out.
So that is actually our
introduction to thermodynamics.
And next time
we're going to talk
about how we're going to
calculate these delta Hr,
these heats of reaction.
So we were talking
about delta H,
and so we want to pull out
the handouts from last time.
And we were at the
bottom of page two
with three different ways
to calculate delta H.
So our delta H of reaction,
delta Hr, the reaction
enthalpy.
So I introduced you
to bond enthalpies,
and today we're
going to look at how
you use bond enthalpies to
calculate reaction enthalpies.
And remember, bond enthalpies--
sometimes it has nothing.
Just delta H.
Sometimes it's delta
H sub B. Capital B for bond.
And we're going to look at that.
Then we're going to look
at how you can calculate
delta H for reaction from
the standard enthalpies
of formation, and I'll introduce
you to what that means.
And then, also tell
you about Hess's law
where you can combine
known reactions that
have known delta H's
to get a new equation
and calculate a new delta
H for that reaction.
So three different ways.
So we're going to start with way
one, which is bond enthalpies.
So here is the equation for
calculating bond enthalpies.
So we have the delta
H0 of the reaction
equals the sum of all
of the reactants bond
enthalpies minus the sum of all
the product bond enthalpies.
And so this is bonds
broken minus bonds formed.
And so let's think
about this for a minute
and think about
what would be true.
If you had stronger bonds in the
products than in the reactants,
what would be true?
And this is a clicker question.
All right.
Let's just take 10 more seconds.
OK Yep.
So now let's think
about why this is true.
So it's good news
that most of you
know that negative means
exothermic and positive
means endothermic.
And let's look at
why this is true.
So let's look at both of these.
So if we have bonds
stronger in the products--
you can just think
about the equation.
So if you are bond
stronger in the products
this is a bigger
number and that's
the smaller number,
which is going
to give you a negative answer.
And a negative
value is exothermic.
And you can think about the
equation stronger bonds here.
A bigger number minus
the smaller number.
Positive or endothermic.
But let's think for a minute
about why this is the case
and rationalize it
because on an exam
this is one of the equations
that you're not given,
so let's help you remember
why this would be true.
We can think about this-- if
you're going to break bonds--
and this isn't in your notes
but people get confused by this,
so I'm just going to write
a little bit on the board.
So if you're going
to break bonds
you need to put energy into
the system to break bonds.
And we talked about this before.
And since we have
exam two coming up
we'll just do a little
review of some of the things
that might be on the exam.
So you don't have this in the
handout we're doing right now,
but you had this in the
lecture nine handout.
And something like this
might be on the exam
so we should be
thinking about it.
So remember, if
there was no energy
that you needed
to put in to break
a bond-- if breaking the bond
required no energy there would
be no bond.
So when the energy is
zero there's no bonds.
These two are not-- these
things are not bonded together.
And when you do form a
bond, you go down an energy
here so it's at a lower state.
It's more stable.
That's why it forms a bond.
If it was less stable it
wouldn't be forming a bond.
But if it's more stable,
lower in energy, a larger
negative number,
then a bond forms.
So to break this bond you have
to put energy into the system.
So breaking bonds always
involves energy in.
But forming bonds-- so if
we're forming bonds then
we're going to have energy out.
So we're at a lower place here.
So if we want to break bonds
we have to put energy in,
but if we're forming
bonds then we're
going to have energy that
these guys had that is
going to be released somewhere.
So energy goes
out of the system.
And the farther down we have the
stronger bonds, the more energy
you have to put in to break.
But also, the more energy that
comes out when the bonds form.
So energy in to break
a bond, but when
a bond is forming it goes to
a lower state and that energy
is released.
So now we can think about
what happens if you have
a reactant with weak bonds.
So if the reactant
then has weak bonds,
how much energy do you have
to put in if it has weak bonds
to break them?
Not a lot.
So we have just sort of a
little bit of energy in.
Little energy in to
break those bonds.
Now in the products, if
we have strong bonds,
how much energy goes out if
we're forming strong bonds?
A lot.
So energy out.
We have lots of energy out.
So that was the first
case that we had.
So we had something where
the bonds were stronger
in the product and we said
that this was negative.
So net here we have heat
or energy out is released,
and so that's an
exothermic system.
Oh, the boards work today.
And if we have the other--
if we have, say, strong bonds
in the reactants, then we have
to put a lot of energy in.
Big energy in.
And if we have weak bonds
that are being formed,
we're not getting
much energy back
so the net here is that you
have heat in or heat absorbed.
And it's an
endothermic reaction.
So this is just one
way to think about it.
Remember, whenever you
are going to break bond
you always have to put
energy in to break the bond.
And when a bond is formed
that energy is released.
So we are thinking about
the net of the processes,
and that's why this
equation works for us.
So keep this in mind.
This is one of the
points that people
get confused on the exams.
And sometimes like they
say, oh, thermodynamics.
I just don't understand
it, and they're not
keeping calm and sciencing on.
They're getting all
stressed by thermodynamics,
and it's only this confusion.
That's it.
So if you work this
out then thermodynamics
will be your friend and you
will love thermodynamics
like I do forever.
Just kind of keep this in mind
and those diagrams in mind
and you'll be all good.
All right.
So let's do an example now.
So we can use these bond
enthalpies in this equation
where we're summing
up all our reactants.
And sometimes you see
some of a little i
here for i reactants
minus j products.
So the sum of all
of the products.
And it really is a lot
here because we're talking
about breaking every bond.
We're talking about
forming every bond.
So this is not a huge
molecule, but let's think
about how many
bonds we're actually
going to be breaking here.
So these are all the
bonds that are broken.
They're not quite as
many being formed here.
So bonds broken.
We have carbon hydrogen bonds,
and we have seven of those.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5-- let's see if
I can count them-- 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7.
There it is.
I need my glasses.
OH bonds.
We have these guys up here.
One, two, three, four, five.
We have CO bond over a
one double bond over here.
So we also are going to
have these ones here.
One, two, three, four, five.
We have the double
bond over there.
We have five carbon bonds.
The one single bond here.
And the carbon bond is one,
two, three, four, five.
And we have OO bonds.
We have six of those.
Thank goodness.
I didn't have to count anymore.
It's already labeled.
And then the bonds formed.
So we're going to have these.
So it's six of those,
so we have 12 altogether
and we have also 12 over here.
So first you have to count.
And counting is not
one of my strengths,
so I don't like
doing it this way
and I'm going to show
you two other ways
to calculate the same thing.
But we can take this
and sum these all up.
We can look up the mean bond
enthalpies for every single one
of these types of
bonds, multiply them
by the appropriate
coefficients, and come up
with a sum for all the
bonds for i number of bonds
that you have in the reactants.
And you can do the same in the
products for j number of bonds
that you have in the products
and come up with these numbers.
So if you were told
that you have to do it
this way-- use bond enthalpies
and you know how to do it--
or if it's an easier problem
and you're only, say,
breaking two things and forming
two things this isn't a bad way
to do it.
For big molecules this
is definitely a nuisance.
And if we sum all of
this up together-- and so
for the total number we have
reactants minus products.
And so if we subtract
this we get minus 2,740.
And the actual value
is minus 2,816.
So it's not even
the best agreement
when you do it this way.
And the reason was, if
you remember last time,
we were talking about the bonds.
Mean bond enthalpy is
about 8% difference.
So if you had, say,
CH in a system that
has all the rest of the
atoms on carbon or H,
that's a somewhat
different value
than if all of
those other H atoms
were substituted with bromine or
if all those other H atoms were
substituted with carbon.
Then the bond enthalpy for that
CH-- it depends on what else
is bonded to the C. And so
there's about 8% difference
usually in the values.
And so overall, you're not
going to get much better.
You certainly are not going
to get better than eight.
So agreement of
3% is pretty good,
but it's not all that
precise because we're
using these mean bond
enthalpies, which
don't depend on the actual
value in that particular system.
So we can do better than this,
and it can be also easier.
And it'll be easier if we use
standard heats of formation.
So this is delta H sub
f, f for formation.
So the delta H sub f
not for standard value
is equal to the
reaction, delta H,
if you're talking about
a reaction that involves
one mole of compound being
derived from its pure elements
in their most stable state
and in their standards state.
So this is standard state
1 bar and room temperature.
So let's calculate for the same
reaction glucose plus oxygen
going to CO2 plus
water and see if we
can get a little bit more
accurate value that way.
So let's think about what's
happening in this reaction.
So every time we oxidize
glucose we're forming water.
And so we can think
about the heat
of formation for liquid water.
So again, this would be one
mole coming from pure elements
in their most standard state.
So we have to think about where
the hydrogen is coming from
and where the oxygen
is coming from.
So hydrogen in its most
stable form is H2 gas,
and oxygen in its most
stable form is O2 gas.
So that's then the equation
balanced for one mole
of H2O liquid being formed.
And we can look up
the delta H for this--
that delta H of formation--
for this reaction as written
is the delta H of formation,
and it's minus 285.83 kilojoules
per mole.
So now let's consider what
else that we're forming, water.
And we're also forming CO2.
So CO2 is derived from carbon
in its most stable state, which
is graphite as we discussed
before, and also O2, oxygen.
And O2 oxygen gas is the
most stable state there.
So for this reaction
as written that
is the delta H of
formation of CO2 gas
and it's minus 393.5
kilojoules per mole.
So those are our products.
We also have two reactants.
One of our reactants is O2.
So it's what's
doing the oxidation.
And we're going from
O2 gas to O2 gas.
This is the most stable state.
So what do you think
the value is here?
AUDIENCE: 0.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: 0.
Yes.
So if you have an
element already
in its most stable state,
its heat of formation
is going to be 0.
Because it's already
the most stable state,
so the heat of formation is 0.
And every year, I think,
on an exam someone's
trying to see if
they can calculate
a delta H of a reaction
and they're looking
and they're like, oh, I want
to use heats of formation
because I know that's a lot
easier but a value is missing
from my table.
And they're like, the value
is missing from the table.
And the TA doesn't know how
much information or whatever
to give.
And if you think you should
have a value on an exam
and you don't think about,
is that element already
in its most standard state?
Perhaps it's zero and that's why
it's not listed on the table.
So keep this in mind.
This can be very
useful to remember.
All right.
One more thing is
involved in the equation.
We have glucose.
So we can think about the
reaction that forms glucose
from elements in its
most stable state,
and we've actually talked
about all these already.
We have O2.
That's in its most stable state.
Carbon graphite.
H2 gas.
And so this reaction
as written--
it has a heat of formation
of minus 1,260 kilojoules
per mole.
So now we can
calculate the delta H
for the oxidation of glucose.
The delta H of the reaction from
these delta H's of formation.
And here's the equation.
Delta H of the reaction
is equal to the sum
of all of the delta
H's of formation
of the products minus the sum
of the delta H's of formation
of the reactants.
So this now is one of
the sources of confusion
because if you're
using bond enthalpies
it's reactants minus products.
If you're using
delta H of formation
it's products minus reactants.
So that's why I
spend a little time
over here thinking about
what's going on with the bond
enthalpies, so hopefully no
one will fall into this delta H
pitfall over here
and you'll keep
the reactions-- the
equations straight.
So now we can plug it in.
If you remember the equations
this is pretty easy.
So we have our
delta H of reaction.
We have 6 times the
heat of formation
of our products over here.
CO2.
6 times the first
product and then
6 times the second
product, which is water,
minus the first reactant,
which is our glucose,
and we have one of those,
and we have 6 oxygens.
So products minus reactants.
Pay attention to
the stoichiometry.
You need to multiply
the heats of formation
by the number of molecules so
then we can put in the values
that we just saw.
C02 minus 392 for our
water minus 285 minus--
and here we have a
minus 1,260 for glucose.
And again, 6 times 0 because
the oxygen is already
in its most stable state.
And if we do the
math correctly, you
get minus 2,816
kilojoules per mole,
and that is exactly
the experimental value.
And it's because the
heats of formation
are also experimental, so
this is a very precise number.
When you use the
heats of formation
you're going to get a much
closer value to experimental.
And this was a bit
easier than thinking
about every bond
that would be broken
and every bond that
would be formed.
One more way that
you can do this.
And this takes
advantage of something
known as Hess's Law and
the fact that enthalpy
is a state function, which means
that it's independent of path.
So if you were
climbing a mountain
and you wanted to go
from point A to point B,
you could climb all the way
up to the top and go back down
or you could just go right from
A to B and it wouldn't matter.
Your delta H would be
the same in both cases
because it's
independent of path.
So it only matters
what the values
are for your reactants
and your final products.
It doesn't matter how you
get from the reactants
to the products.
Delta H is going to be the same.
And because of this, you
can take different routes
if their equations for
different parts of your reaction
that are already known
with values of delta
H-- you can add those equations
together and then add together
the delta H's to
get a new value.
So Hess's Law-- if there are
two or more equations that
are added to give another
chemical equations
then you can add up the delta
H for the reactions of each
of the individual
equations to get
the sum for your new equation.
So let's do this now, again,
for glucose and oxygen.
So if we have these
three equations
here-- this one
is showing glucose
plus oxygen being broken
down to the elements that
are in the most stable state.
So graphite, H2
and O2 for glucose.
And then our 6 O2s are
there on both sides
because it's already in
the most stable state.
We're going to be forming CO2
from the elements in the most
stable state and also water.
So we can add these
together, paying attention
to the stoichiometry.
So we need to multiply this
equation by 6 and this equation
by 6, and then we should be
able to do some canceling
and make sure that we're getting
our equation of interest.
So we can cancel these
6 O2s with these,
we can cancel these
O2s with these,
and we can cancel
this H2 with this.
And that leaves us with
glucose plus 6 oxygens going
to 6 CO2s and 6 waters.
So this is going to work now.
And now, since we added
this together to get this,
we can add our
delta H of reactions
together to get a new
delta H of reaction.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to cancel my graphites.
There we go.
Now we're good.
Didn't notice them there.
So our delta H for reaction.
We saw before that the
formation of CO2 from elements
in its most stable
state was minus,
so now we've just changed
the sign because now we're
going the opposite direction.
So we have a positive value
for that delta H of reaction.
Now we have 6 times
the heat of formation
of CO2 and 6 times the
heat of formation of water
because that's what
those equations are.
Those are the heat of
formation reactions.
And if we add this all
together then we get the number
that we saw before.
So it doesn't matter
what path we take.
We're going to get
to that same answer.
And this one, since
we're using information
that all has to do
with heat of formation,
it's not really very different
from the one we did before.
But you can use
Hess's Law for delta H
of reactions that are
not heats of formation.
If equations are available
that can be added
or summed to get
your net reaction,
then you can add or subtract
these values to get a new delta
H. Don't forget
kilojoules per mole.
So we have our three different
ways-- bond enthalpies,
heat of formation,
and Hess's Law.